نعم هناك حديث بين عناصر الانقاذ يبدو ان
هذا الشخص باسل لو سمحت هذا الشخص يمسك
بالشاشه او بجهاز يتحكم بالكاميرا التي تم
ادخالها ويبدو انه انهم يرصدون رصد شيء ما
لا ادري ما هو بالضبط لكنهم ادخلوا كاميرا
الى داخل الثغره ويتحكمون فيها عن بعد
ويبدو انهم يطلبون الصمت صمت اخر نعم اذا
لحظات الصمت متكرره
لفرق الانقاذ المتواجدين
في قهرمان مرعش وفي هذا الحي المدمر
بالكامل كما ذكر لنا مفيد العربيه غسان حي
كامل مدمر اثراء الزلزال ولكن ما زالت
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره لاي احياء تحت
الانقاظ وبالفعل في الدقائق الاخيره وفي
الساعه الاخيره شاهدنا معكم اخراج شقيقتين
وشاهدنا اخراج ونشهد الان عمليه محاوله
اخراج الشقيقه الثالثه البالغه من العمر 7
سنوات لحظات صمت متكرره لمحاوله سماع صوت
الطفله مجددا ومحاوله تحديد موقعها ايضا
من دون
الحدوث او من دون التسبب باي ضرر لها او
سقوط اي ركام او تحرك اي ركام من فوقها
كما تعلمون هذه اللحظات حساسه جدا ولحظات
يعني حرجه جدا وفرق الانقاذ يعملون بشكل
مستمر ليتمكنوا من اخراج هذه الطفله